so we've got a right triangle drawn over
here where this base is length is a the
height here is B and the length of the
hypotenuse is C and we already know when
we see something like this we know from
the Pythagorean theorem the relationship
between a B and C we know that a squared
plus B squared is going to be equal to
the hypotenuse squared is going to be
equal to C squared what I want to do in
this video is explore how we can relate
trig functions to this to essentially
the Pythagorean theorem and to do that
let's pick one of these non right angles
so let's pick this angle right over here
as theta and let's just think about this
what the sine of theta is and what the
cosine of theta is and see if we can
mess with them a little bit to somehow
leverage the Pythagorean theorem so
before we do that let's just write down
sohcahtoa just so we remember the
definitions of these trig functions so
sine is opposite over hypotenuse cut
cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse and
Toa
tan is opposite over adjacent we won't
be using tan at least in this video so
let's think about sine of theta so sine
of theta I will do it I'll do it in this
blue color so sine of theta is what it
is opposite over hypotenuse so it is
equal to the length of B or it is equal
to B B is the length B over the length
of the hypotenuse which is C now what is
cosine of theta cosine of theta
well the adjacent side the the side of
this angle that is not the hypotenuse it
has length a so it's the length of the
adjacent side over the length of the
hypotenuse now how could I relate these
things well it seems like if I square
sine of theta then I'm going to have
sine squared theta is equal to B squared
over C squared and cosine squared theta
is going to be a squared over C squared
seems like I might be able to add them
to get something that's pretty close up
of Aggron theorem here so let's try that
out so sine squared theta is equal to B
squared over C squared
I just squared both sides so over C
squared cosine squared theta
cosine squared squared theta is equal to
a squared over C squared over C squared
so what's this sum what's sine squared
theta plus cosine squared theta so sine
squared theta plus cosine squared theta
cosine squared theta is going to be
equal to what sine squared theta is B
squared over C squared B squared over C
squared plus a squared plus a squared
over C squared a squared over C squared
which is going to be equal to well we
have a common denominator of C squared
and the numerator we have B squared plus
a squared B squared plus a squared now
what is B squared in it plus a squared
well we have it right over here
Pythagorean theorem tells us B squared
plus a squared where a squared plus B
squared is going to be equal to C
squared so this numerator simplifies to
C squared and the whole expression is C
squared over C squared which is just
equal to one so using the sohcahtoa
definition in a future video we'll use
the unit circle definition but you see
just using the unit's just even using
the sohcahtoa definition of our trig
functions we see probably the most
important of all the trig identities
that the sine squared theta sine squared
of an angle plus the cosine squared of
that same angle I'm introducing orange
unnecessarily plus the cosine squared of
that same angle is going to be equal to
one now you might probably say okay Sal
that's kind of cool but what's the big
deal about this why should I care about
this well the big deal is now you give
me the sine of an angle and I can solve
this equation for the cosine of that
angle or vice versa so this is actually
a pretty a pretty powerful powerful
thing and this is also part of the
motivation even for the unit circle
definition of trig functions